was heute innerhalb von sekunden
übermittelt werden kann konnte früher
tage oder sogar wochen dauern
das verschicken von nachrichten an
freunde und familie ist gegenwärtig
einfacher als je zuvor
und dank moderner kryptographie sind die
geteilten informationen vor fremden
zugriffen ja auch geschützt oder im
letzten video meiner quanten serie habe
ich euch die quantencomputer vorgestellt
eine neue technologie die klassische
computer in einigen wichtigen bereichen
überschatten wird
und genau diese technologie stellt für
die heutige verschlüsselung eine große
gefahr dar
aber keine panik die wissenschaft hat
bereits eine lösung gefunden eine lösung
die diesem wettrüsten womöglich ein ende
bereiten wird
im heutigen video nehmen wir einmal die
sogenannte quantenkryptographie genauer
unter die lupe
[Musik]
bevor wir uns in der welt der
quantenkryptografie führen sollten wir
vielleicht erst einmal klarstellen wie
so wie sie überhaupt brauchen um das
generelle prinzip der verschlüsselung zu
verstehen wenn wir jetzt erst einmal mit
einer einfachen sogenannten substitution
an
als beispiel wollen wir jemandem eine
geheime botschaft nämlich doktor watson
per nachricht verraten um zu verhindern
dass eine unbefugte dritte person diese
geheime botschaft lesen kann ersetzen
wir einfach jeden buchstaben mit seinem
vorgänger im alphabet
so bekommen wir nach der verschlüsselung
diese unlesbaren worte wenn wir den
vorgesehenen empfänger jetzt verraten
dass er jeden buchstaben mit seinem
alphabetischen nachfolger ersetzen muss
dann kann dieser die nachricht
entziffern
diese anleitungen zur entzifferung wird
in der kryptographie auch als schlüssel
bezeichnet eine dritte person müsste
hier zum lesen unserer geheime nachricht
erst einmal diesen schlüssel
herausfinden
natürlich ist das alles aber ein stark
vereinfachtes beispiel die methoden
heutiger kryptographie sind zum glück
viel komplizierter als das jedes mal
wenn du eine nachricht verschickt oder
einen online shop deines vertrauens
seine persönlichen daten speichern soll
werden die übertragenen informationen in
zahlen übersetzt
diese zahlen können dann durch
mathematische funktionen so verändert
werden dass man nur mit dem richtigen
schlüsse schnell genug an die
eigentlichen informationen heran kommt
die resultierenden zahlen sind oft
tausende stellen lang wodurch die
berechnung des schlüssels per hand
unmöglich wird
unbefugte sind also gezwungen den
schlüssel mit computern durch das trial
and error prinzip zu kalkulieren
dieser prozess dauert selbst mit den
fortschrittlichsten modernen algorithmen
auf herkömmlichen rechnern jahrzehnte
jahrhunderte oder sogar bis zum hitzetod
des universums je nachdem wie gut die
verschlüsselung ist das ist übrigens
auch der grund warum ein langes passwort
viel besser ist als ein kompliziertes
genau auf dieser tatsache basiert die
sicherheit der kryptographie von heute
kein klassischer computer kann in
absehbarer zeit einen gut gewählten
schlüssel berechnet
diese stärke könnte aber leider bald zur
sicherheitslücke werden für die
quantencomputer in vielerlei hinsicht
die neuen meister des parallelen
prozessieren ist das aufbringen der
nötigen rechenleistung nämlich kein
problem
was also mit der datensicherheit kommen
die ersten quantencomputer bald alle an
meine geheimen informationen heran
vermutlich nicht denn einige
wissenschaftler sind bereits auf dem
besten weg die wichtige aufgabe der
datenverschlüsselung ein für allemal zu
lösen
[Musik]
in meinem video zu qualmen technologien
hier oben findet ihr bereits eine sehr
kurze grundlegende einführung in die
quantenkryptographie da habe ich das
vorgehen anhand dem wohl bekanntesten
bereits kommerziell verfügbaren
verfahren erklärt dem so genannten
quanten schlüssel austauschen diese
methode basiert auf der normalen
heutigen kryptographie nutzt aber wie
alle anderen verfahren der
quantenkryptografie auch die
physikalischen effekte der
quantenmechanik zu ihrem vorteil der
erste schritt jeder verschlüsselten
übertragung ist das festlegen des
schlüssels an sich beim quanten
schlüssel austausch wird das wie folgt
bewältigt das ziel von uns und unserem
empfänger nennen wir sie einmal laura
ist es auf einen zufälligen schlüssel
zukommen die in ein unbefugter dritter
nicht mithören kann hier für schicke ich
laura eine sequenz an photonen die wir
jeweils in eine von vier möglichen
richtungen polarisieren vertikal
horizontal links oder rechts diagonal
laura empfängt jetzt diese photonen
abwechselnd mit jeweils einem von ihren
zwei eigenen polarisations detektoren
einer lässt vertikal polarisiertes licht
durch und blockiert horizontale wellen
der andere lässt links diagonales licht
durch und blockiert rechts diagonale
wählen
schafft es ein foto und zur anderen
seite des detektors schreibt sich laura
eine 1 auf wenn nicht eine null
und hier kommt das wichtige detail ist
laura zum beispiel ein vertikal
polarisiertes foto mit dem diagonalen
detector dann besteht eine
fünfzigprozentige wahrscheinlichkeit
dass es durch konnte es besteht also
eine 50 prozentige chance dass sie sich
das falsche bild aufschreibt
am ende des prozesses hat laura also
eine sequenz angemessenen witz und die
jeweils verwendeten filter um hieraus
einen sicheren schlüssel zu entnehmen
gleiche ich unsere tatsächlich
verwendeten polarisationsfilter mit
lauras verwendeten detektoren ab jedes
mal wenn sie für ein foto an den
falschen detector genutzt hat wird er
zusammen mit dem gemessenen photonen
also dem bild aus der sequenz entfernt
wegen der möglichkeit eines zufälligen
treffers 50 ist es schließlich wichtig
dass sowohl wir als auch laura die
richtigen filter benutzen lieber ist es
tatsächlich egal ob die sequenz an
filtern öffentlich zugänglich ist oder
nicht sind alle filter abgeglichen dann
entsteht eine sequenz aus bitz mit der
man jetzt informationen auf
konventionelle art und weise wieder
verschlüsseln kann diese sequenz ist
nämlich nichts anderes als eine lange
zeit und zahlen können wir wie gewohnt
in eine ganz normale mathematische
funktion zur verschlüsselung einbauen
okay aber wieso ist die nutzung eines
quanten kanals zum schlüssel austausch
jetzt so sicher
und wieso ist es egal ob die reihenfolge
der verwendeten filter öffentlich ist
die wichtige information ist nicht die
sequenz an filtern sondern die
reihenfolge an photonen und damit die
biz auf die wir uns geeinigt haben
während des schlüssel austauschs werden
rein zufällig polarisierte photonen
verschickt welche dann mit zufällig
gewählten detektoren gemessen werden
die empfangenen biz die also aus der
sequenz entfernt werden sind 100%
zufällig ein ungewollter mit höherer
müsste trotz seines wissens der
detektoren reihenfolge die richtige
sequenz an photonen durch diese filter
jagen
ein unmögliches vorhaben bei genug
photonen und diesen grad an zufälligkeit
es kommt aber noch besser will der mit
höherer diese photonen stattdessen
direkt am quanten kanal abhören würde er
der quantenmechanik und damit den
grundgesetzen der physik zum opfer
fallen
verwendet er nämlich den falschen
detektor an der falschen stelle
verändert er das foto ein physikalisch
auf permanente art und weise diese
störung im kanal lässt sich dann während
des filter abgleich zwischen mir und
laura feststellen
egal was der bösewicht versucht er kann
nicht unbemerkt an unseren schlüssel
herankommen
natürlich ist diese methode noch alles
andere als ausgereift das momentane
problem ist vor allem die instabilität
der quantenzustände kleinste störungen
im quanten kanal können zur verfälschung
der quantenteilchen führen so einen
quanten kanal konnten wissenschaftler
zum beispiel bisher nur über ein paar
hundert kilometer auf dem land oder mit
licht zwischen satelliten während der
nacht erfolgreich etablieren
das ist natürlich schon ein riesiger
erfolg aber große distanzen wie man sie
im alltag bräuchte führen leider noch zu
oft zu verfälschen zuständen der
photonen
nichtsdestotrotz schreitet die forschung
in diesem bereich stetig voran
aber was machen wir eigentlich wenn wir
nicht vertrauen können
auch hierfür gibt es zumindest in der
theorie bereits eine lösung
nehmen wir einmal an wir haben mit laura
jetzt dank unserer sicheren
verschlüsselung erfolgreich über einen
dieses thema diskutieren können stehe
nun aber vor einer finalen entscheidung
werden wir eine gewisse optional die uns
selbst am besten in den kram passt oder
wählen wir eine andere option b welche
laura wiederum bevorzugen würde für uns
beide würde die jeweils andere option
zusätzlichen stress bedeuten weshalb wir
auf jeden fall unsere eigene option
bevorzugen würden
zum glück gibt es hier für sogenannte
commitment verfahren während eines
solchen prozesses kann eine partei einen
wert festlegen ohne ihnen der anderen
partei zu verraten
gleichzeitig kann die festlegen der
partei den wert aber auch nicht mehr
verändern
in der quantenkryptographie gibt es hier
für den sogenannten crunch um coinflip
also den quanten münzwurf das prinzip
eines münzwurf ist uns allen ja bekannt
um zwischen zwei optionen eine
entscheidung zu treffen wird eine münze
geworfen welche mit fünfzigprozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit entweder auf der
seite bezahlt oder der seite mit dem
kopf landet der einzige nachteil ist
jedoch dass sie für beide parteien am
selben ort sein müssen
ansonsten könnte die partei die den
münzwurf ausführt schließlich einfach
behaupten dass die münze auf der jeweils
bevorzugten seite gelandet ist
genau dieses prinzip zum treffen eine
entscheidung kann dank der
quantenmechanik durch einen quanten
kanal ersetzt werden und das
funktioniert so genau wie beim quanten
schlüssel austausch werden auch hier
wieder unsere vier verschiedenen
polarisation von photonen genutzt
horizontal vertikal links und rechts
diagonal
wir müssen jetzt laura im quanten kanal
eine sequenz an photonen schicken
hierbei dürfen wir selbst nur eins der
zwei paare an filtern nutzen entweder
horizontal und vertikal oder die beiden
diagonalen dieses mal ist es wichtig
unsere filter wahl muss geheim bleiben
für uns könnten zum beispiel alle
vertikalen polarisierten photonen eine
null darstellen und alle horizontalen
eine 1 da laura nichts von den benutzten
filtern weiß könnten sowohl vertikale
und links diagonale eine null darstellen
während horizontale und rechts diagonale
photonen 1 1 sein können
es ist jetzt ihre aufgabe zu erraten
welches paar an filtern nicht benutzt
habe laura empfängt nun also an ihrem
ende die sequenz an photonen
sie kann ihre polarisation entweder mit
einem horizontalen oder einem rechts
diagonalen filter messen wurde ein foto
an blockiert schreibt sie sich eine 0
aufgelegt das auf die andere seite
dann schreibt sie sich eine 1 auf
logisch ist sie meine horizontal und
vertikal polarisierten photonen mit dem
horizontalen filter dann bekommt sie
dieselbe sequenz von nullen und einsen
die ich hier ursprünglich geschickt habe
da sie aber nicht weiß welchen filter
sie benutzen muss besteht eine
fünfzigprozentige wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie den falschen wählt und durch
ihre messungen verfälsche müsst ihr zum
beispiel ein vertikales photon mit einem
diagonalen filter dann besteht eine
fünfzigprozentige wahrscheinlichkeit
dass dieses foto und blockiert wird sie
hat also keine ahnung ob sie jetzt den
richtigen filter gewählt hat und das 1 0
sein sollte oder ob das der falsche
filter war und das photon eigentlich
eine eins war
sobald sie fertig mit ihren messungen
ist müsste laura theoretisch eine
tabelle mit zwei spalten haben in der
ersten hat sie alle bits aufgeschrieben
die sie mit dem horizontalen filter
gemessen hat und in der zweiten alle
ergebnisse vom diagonalen filtern
jetzt liegt es an ihr meine filter war
richtig zu erraten etwas wofür die
wahrscheinlichkeit der korrektheit bei
exakt 50 prozent liegt es ist also
genauso wie beim münzwurf hat sie ihre
wahl getroffen gebe ich meine
ursprüngliche witzig wenn es durch die
werte dieser sequenz müssten jetzt den
aufgeschriebenen werten von laura an den
jeweiligen stellen entsprechen
zumindest wenn sie richtig geraten hat
gebe ich übrigens die falschen werte
durch dann weiß laura dass ich lüge
red sie nämlich richtig und ich versuche
ihre gemessenen blitzt es tatsächlich
nicht verwendeten filters zu erraten
dann werde ich mit bei einer 100
prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit einen
fehler machen
es gibt also keine möglichkeit bei
diesem münzwurf zu schummeln
genauso würde also ein quanten münster
funktionieren
der würde es uns erlauben entscheidungen
zusammen mit einer partei zu treffen der
wir das lügen unter bestimmten umständen
zutrauen würden
bisher haben wir uns aber nur mit einer
welt auseinander gesetzt in der alle
parteien einen quantencomputer besitzen
alle haben dieselbe rechenleistung
da das aber nicht der realität
entspricht gibt es viele aspekte die uns
jetzt wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht
bewusst sind
abschließend bleibt also noch zu
erwähnen was denn mit den klassischen
computern in einer welt der
quantencomputer passiert hierfür
arbeitet die wissenschaft ebenfalls
bereits an einer lösung
[Musik]
die sogenannte post quantenkryptografie
befasst sich nicht etwa mit einer welt
in der quantencomputer die
quantenkryptographie umgehen können das
ist physikalisch unmöglich stattdessen
geht es hierbei vielmehr um eine
absolute sicherheit bei der
quantencomputer selbst gegen klassische
computer keine chance haben deswegen
wird die post quantenkryptographie auch
als spannten resistente kryptographie
bezeichnet die einzige überlegenheit der
quantencomputer ist schließlich nur die
rechenleistung es sind keine magischen
maschinen die alles knacken können
man versucht also bereits ein
kryptographische system zu entwickeln
das sowohl bei quantencomputern als auch
bei klassischen computern sicherheit
garantieren kann
die bisher vorgestellten
quantenkryptografie methoden sind zwar
schön und gut benötige aber einen
quantencomputer auf beiden seiten und
vor allem einen quanten kanal
wir hatten bereits im video zu
quantencomputern festgestellt
quantencomputer sind nicht perfekt und
klassische kombination hat trotz allem
ihre vorteile
es gibt also für beide platz in unserer
welt so verrückt und gefährlich die
quantencomputer auch klingen mögen
unsere daten werden in der zukunft trotz
neuer technologien immer sicherer werden
[Musik]
dass sie ist der vierte teil meiner
serie zum thema quanten in kooperation
mit dem bundesministerium für bildung
und forschung
wenn ihr euch etwas verloren gefühlt
haben und nicht so ganz genau wusste was
ist jetzt mit quanten und so alles auf
sich hat dann kann ich empfehlen aber
die ersten drei teile meiner quanten
serie zu schauen hier oben habe ich eine
playlist verlinkt da gehe ich auf die
grundlagen der quantenmechanik ein danke
fürs zuschauen und wie immer bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]